In a way I've been really
thinking a lot in Microsoft, and
how to design
a conversational AI system.
Cortana is just one of them.
Another why I want to
bring your attention to,
is actually Chatbots.
So we actually shipped as
a first Chatbot in China,
about three and
a half years ago.
It is called Xiaoice in China.
Now actually, she has about
100 million users in China and
they're talking to her,
on average, 23 turns.
And she's actually very,
very talented in China and
then she's even hosting a TV
program, morning news program in
Shanghai with over 800
million viewership.
And she recently actually
demonstrated her ability to
write poems.
She actually published a poetry
book amazingly, helped
the Chinese users to write
over 2 million poems.
And just so you understand that
the scale, the number of poems.
That's more than all
the poems ever published
in the history of China.
So that's only in China.
In Japan, a year later,
we actually launched in Japan
called Rinna, the chatbot Rinna.
And it's even more
popular in Japan, 25% of
Japanese population have already
talked to Rinna in Japan.
And she's also now
powering a chatbot for
Nintendo's Pokemon, so.
And then of course right here
in the United States as some of
you might remember exactly
a year ago we celebrated
the arrival of Zo,
our own chatbot here in the US.
In just a year I'm
happy to tell you that
she actually has over
a million users.
Just like Xiaoice and
Rinna, and Zo actually
has developed several AI driven
senses like voice recognition,
image recognition, and
the social commenting, and
the natural language
understanding.
People can now rhyme with Zo in
a rap battle, and it's really
amazing, or challenge her for
a game of Exploding Kittens.
Or even interact with
her newest friend,
Poppy, a popular YouTuber.
It's just amazing the things
that you can do with
the chatbots.
But then you might wonder,
so why did you pay so
much attention to chatbots?
Let me just say that chit
chat Is characteristic
of human beings, just go
home and think about this.
So most of the intelligent
agents today like Siri or
Cortana focus on passive
completion or IQ.
Get things done within the skill
chaining like what you just saw
from Christina's demo,
is fabulous.
It's really helping
get things done.
But it is the emotional
intelligence, or
the EQ, that enables sustained
conversations or dialogues,
which will be critical to truly
understand the human users.
So by engaging with the people
on a much more social and
personal level, and our chatbots
are developing their EQ's.
So learning how to react,
respond,
and then based on the data that
from those human interaction.
So then,
we can take those learnings and
apply them to many
other products.
So if course you know, in
Microsoft, not only we do those
conversational AI products,
we also make sure that our AI
investment will be infused into
all Microsoft products and
services, that it drive deeper
and more personal experiences.
The first place we start
of course would be Windows.
You know, Windows is already
using machine learning and
computer vision, for example,
to help you to personalize
your photos and videos.
It's really amazing to think
about the explosion of digital
photos.
On average, for
a Windows user, In every year,
the user would take
52,000 photos.
There's no way you can keep
track of so many photos and to
do something with those photos
until now, with the help of AI.
Let's roll the video and
show you what we have been doing
with Windows photo in the video.
>> Today,
we capture more photos and
videos than ever
before in history.
And we are building a suite of
AI driven tools within Microsoft
Photos to transform the way of
the next generation of Windows
users' dreams, captures,
and expresses themselves.
This month we shipped a brand
new search system that uses
machine learning to let you
find people, places and
things in your photos.
To give you a starting point for
creating videos we've created
systems that automatically
generate movies from your media.
Special effects are some of
the most coveted feature by our
Gen Z audience.
So we are using
computer vision and
AI to track objects
in your videos.
Just ink a doodle,
anchor it, and
watch it follow
something in the video.
We are excited to be bringing
differentiated experiences
based on AI and
machine learning to over 250
million devices every month.
>> Everything is going to become
more intelligent as you think
about that.
Managing of files, creating,
and all those things.